- So wait, is it true that
you've gotten into hypnotherapy
because I have never done it.
I'm afraid to do it, but I wanna do it.
- What are you afraid of?
- I'm afraid that like,
someone's gonna get me
to do something like, and I'm just not,
it's like, I want somebody
else to be in the room
to make sure no one messes with me.
- So you don't end up doing
like the chicken dance.
- Yes.
(indistinct)
- I literally said
chicken dance in my head
and I didn't want to sound
weird, but you did, so okay.
- Yeah, so I found a woman
who's really great at it,
and I really like it.
It's not as crazy as those
Vegas shows would tell you.
I don't like start and then I'm
like, anything could happen.
- But why did you do it?
What was your reasoning?
- I was interested.
I was interested in
finding a form of therapy
that just felt different.
- That's my thing.
Like any kinda like trauma
is that like helpful?
- You're able to almost
rewrite your own past.
So you're able to see and experience,
but you are controlling it.
It's not like the hypnotherapist
is guiding you through it.
So you get to go back and go like,
I would like to rewrite
this and view this moment.
That's probably not that big of a trauma.
Maybe I saw that one.
- Oh, it's like almost looking
at it from a vantage point, different-
- You get to see your past from now,
but you're also making it up a little bit.
So you can kinda make it more positive
in how you want it to be.
- This is something everyone should do.
- Well, totally.
- We all have trauma.
Yeah.
- I know that for me,
I've really loved it.
And the other side is it's really fun.
And I think that if you're
doing something for self-help,
it's also okay to enjoy it.
- Yeah.
Okay, you wanna know something funny?
(laughing)
My therapist was like,
literally her advice to me
was stop reading self-help
or any educational thing.
(laughing)
- How come?
- She was like, you need to stop.
- [Jake] It got too long.
- Like, you need to read
some kind of fiction because I obsess-
- You read a mystery.
- Just read
some Agatha Christie.
She's like, you need to not,
I wanna next time we talk,
I don't want you to be like
so I read this and-
- And that one, yeah.
- Yeah.
Cause I just love
- Yeah, absolutely.
- like everyone's perspective on life
and like what they're learning.
I just love knowing what I could learn.
I'm a last born.
So I feel like that's,
I'm used to like kind of-
- You watch the older people
- Exactly.
- do it and you make your adjustments.
- Yes, we're the perfect
sucker for a self-help.
(laughing)
- It's like, well, look, I'm
talking about hypnotherapy
on the Kelly Clarkson Show.
- I'm into it though.
I really have wanted to do it
but I wanted like trust
the person I'm going to.
So I'm totally gonna get the number.
- Yeah, I find it really fun and I feel
like that self helps.
If you're gonna do it,
you might as well enjoy it
'cause it's really just
like a weird hobby.
- And it's not, I'm still
obeying what my therapist says.
- You do?
- It's something different.
(laughing)
- Yeah, totally.
- It's not a self-help work.
And it's like educational things,
I'm just obsessed with anyway.